un secret pour personne que je ne suis
pas un
partisan
d'Emmanuel Macron ni d'adepte de sa
politique mais comment ne pas être
d'accord avec ce propos
la civilisation c'est le contraire de la
barbarie
qui ne voit monter la sauvagerie la
violence et quelque chose qui est le
contraire de la civilisation c'est pas
là ce n'est pas la première fois dans
notre histoire la dernière fois qu'on a
vu la vague de la barbarie sur
surmonter tout le reste c'est dans les
années 30 la barbarie nazie on a vu
aussi la barbarie stalinienne
qui peut penser que lorsqu'on voit les
images de l'assaut du Capitole aux
États-Unis on n'est pas en face d'une
bouffée de violence
inimaginable quelques années auparavant
même quelques mots auparavant qui peut
penser que la journée ou des pardon je
vous coupe sur mettons sur le Capitole
peut-être que je vais vous ça va vous
choquer ma question mais
il n'y a pas eu de blessé au Capitole
est-ce que c'est plus violent ce qui se
passe au capital ou ce qu'on voit par
exemple place de la Concorde certains
soirs de manifestations c'est plus
violent parce que la dimension
symbolique est pas du tout la même ce
qui s'est passé au Canada
mais c'était des manifestants qui sont
qui sont morts et un policier et un
policier qui est mort aussi mais
la violence symbolique est pas la même
que la violence des manifestations
auxquelles on assiste la violence
symbolique du Capitole elle est de même
nature que celle du 6 février 34 c'est à
dire que il se passe quelque chose qui
ne pouvait pas se passer dans ton
imaginait pas aux États-Unis cela puisse
se passer rappelez-vous
Raymond Aron disait le seul pays en
Occident qui est qui n'est pas
susceptible de connaître une révolution
ce sont les États-Unis et là on a une
image de violence
contre ce qui était jusque là quasiment
sacré aux États-Unis même si au coup
d'Américains n'aiment pas Washington
n'aime pas l'état fédéral attaquer le
Capitole c'était inimaginable donc ça ça
témoigne d'une pulsion de violence très
profonde et ça ça nous montre un pays
divisé jusqu'au point où une partie de
la population pourraient très bien
s'attaquer à l'autre un autre parti et
c'est ce qu'on cette fracture des
sociétés cette violence qui monte dans
les sociétés occidentales et d'ailleurs
dans le dans le monde entier mais en
particulier qui touche les sociétés
occidentales qui se pensaient tellement
civilisé et tellement à l'abri de tout
cela
elle nous saute aux yeux partout je dire
la journée le jour où la police a perdu
le contrôle de Paris pendant les
manifestations des gilets jaunes on a vu
piller l'Arc de Triomphe
on a assisté à quelque chose d'inouïe
terme de retour de la violence et puis
ça c'est la violence symbolique la plus
forte mais il y a aussi la violence de
tous les jours et aussi les menaces de
mort quand vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
une minorité agissante il y a aussi la
violence verbale il y a la violence
physique qui monte on a parlant des
années expliqué que c'était un sentiment
la violence physique elle déborde de
partout
précisément qu'est-ce qu'elle est votre
regard sur ce qui s'est passé à
Saint-Brévin
que c'est un signe de plus de de cette
violence qui monte dans la dans la
société alors violence qui est faite aux
hommes parce qu'on leur impose des
centres d'accueil d'immigrés pour les
répartir sur le territoire sans demander
la vie de personne alors on sait bien
que la vie serait sans doute très
négatif mais
il n'empêche
des gens qui se sentent qui ont le
sentiment qu'on leur fait violence en
leur imposant quelque chose dont ils ne
veulent pas et puis il y a des gens qui
réagissent
à ce dont ils ne veulent pas d'une façon
extraordinairement violente personne ne
peut quel que soit son avis sur la
répartition des
clandestins des réfugiés sur le
territoire personne ne peut accepter
cette idée qu'il est normal de brûler la
maison du maire l'enquête mais c'est
dans cette dans notre société ça devient
presque banal attaquer des élus attaquer
des soignants à l'hôpital
m'attaquer des des des enseignants voir
les décapiter il y a une espèce de
banalisation d'une d'une violence qui
est qui est extraordinairement
inquiétante et qui touche toutes les
institutions toutes les autorités et
même les citoyens ordinaires il y a un
peu plus de 20 ans une commissaire qui
s'appelait le commissaire Lucienne
Butron écrivait à vous un livre sur les
violences urbaines dans lesquelles elle
mais elle classifiait les l classé la
gravité des violences et elle était
justement elle mettait au-dessus des des
violences les violences contre les
tasses que vous appelez les les
violences symboliques
ce livre ce constat il est fait à la fin
des années Jospin donc il y a il y a
plus de 20 ans comment expliquer vous
que on ne se soit pas plus on n'est pas
plus attaqué la question qu'on soit pas
plus attaquée aux problèmes qu'on n'est
pas plus
vous voyez bien quand le président de la
République on peut critiquer sa
politique sa façon de d'agir de se poser
la question de savoir quelle est sa part
à lui de responsabilité comme comme de à
chacun d'entre nous mais regardez le
résultat
les réactions
honteux d'utiliser ce terme le mot
civilisation d'abord et des
civilisations sous prétexte que tel ou
tel écrivain un peu radical ou très
radical les a utilisés pour nos camions
en l'occurrence Renault camion en
l'occurrence mais on peut plus parler de
Patrick parce que le marchand de patrie
enfin bien sûr les mots peuvent avoir
peuvent être avoir été lestés dans
l'histoire si vous prenez le triptyque
travail famille patrie évidemment ça
vous renvoie quelque chose de
particulier mais si vous prenez chacun
de ces mots après l'autre ce sont tous
des mots que nous utilisons nous aucune
raison de ne pas utiliser donc la
question de la civilisation et par
conséquent du recul de la civilisation
de la civilité ou la décibilisation si
on veut l'appeler ainsi mais c'est un
mot qui mais c'est très parlant fait
scandale vous vous rendez compte donc
tout est résumé là-dedans tout est
résumé dans ces réactions pendant des
années il a été impossible
de parler de la montée de la violence on
vous opposez toujours des chiffres qui
va aller ce qui va les faire pas grand
chose en général pour vous expliquer que
ça n'était pas vrai que c'était un
fantasme ça ne venait pas que de la
gauche
rappelez-vous l'éducation nationale il
n'y avait pas de montée de la violence à
l'école
si vous désirez le contraire on vous
opposez les chiffres et on vous disait
mais regardez vous racontez n'importe
quoi jusqu'au jour où c'est déclencher
vous savez le mouvement pas de vagues et
où les enseignants vont expliquer que
si on la voyait pas dans les
statistiques c'est tout simplement parce
qu'on découragé les enseignants de
signaler ces événements parce que les
l'administration ne les enregistrait pas
parce que pas de vagues pendant des
décennies pendant des décennies nous
avons voulu fermer les yeux
collectivement au fond sur la façon dont
notre monde et en particulier nos
sociétés occidentales se dégradaient
mais c'est vrai pour la violence c'est
vrai pour le pouvoir d'achat c'est fait
pour les fractures sociales c'est vrai
pour la tout ce qui tout ce qui atteint
touche à la décomposition de nos
sociétés et de notre forme de
civilisation et de nos formes de
civilité voilà donc
ça n'a rien d'étonnant il suffit il
faudrait simplement ouvrir les yeux la
vérité c'est que nous avons considéré
que ça ne pouvait plus nous arriver
voilà et bien si ça nous arrive
on va y revenir justement concernant
notamment la guerre en Ukraine mais il y
a un certain nombre de réactions
puisqu'on a parlé de Saint-Brévin dans
le dans le chat puisque les internautes
commencent toutes en nous écoutant ayant
vous écoutant Henri Guaino et pas mal
sur sur Saint-Brévin
si on élargit un peu la question est-ce
que de votre point de vue du point de
vue de gaulisme que vous êtes il faut un
référendum sur l'immigration
et de vous pour ou contre l'immigration
il faut pas référendum un référendum
c'est un homme sur un projet de loi
c'est Approuvez-vous le projet de loi
qui est annexé tout dépend ce qui a dans
quel serait quel sera un bon référendum
sur l'immigration quel sera un bon
projet de loi il y a plusieurs choses il
y a
à mon avis c'est plusieurs projets de
loi ça ne peut pas faire qu'un seul
projet de loi sinon il y a plus de débat
possible donc il y a d'abord la
récupération des instruments
de
notre indépendance notre capacité notre
souveraineté nos capacités sur la
capacité à exercer notre souveraineté la
souveraineté personne vous l'enlève vous
pouvez toujours dire non vous pouvez
toujours refuser d'appliquer des traités
des règles c'est c'est le droit
absolument inaffaçable d'un peuple on
pouvait pas le retirer un peu mais les
moyens de l'exercer vous pouvez y
renoncer vous pouvez les remettre à
d'autres c'est ce qui se passe depuis
des décennies là encore on a voulu on a
cessé de nous expliquer que nous allions
retrouver notre indépendance
sous-ensemble sinon nous la perdrions
que nous allions retrouver les moyens de
notre soin de tous ensemble si on nous
les aurions plus ils se trouvent
maintenant clair que si nous ne
récupérons pas les moyens d'exercer dans
certains domaines de souveraineté nous
ne pourrons pas l'exercer les élections
de serviront plus à rien quelque chose
qui est plus large que l'immigration
enfin en tous les cas oui mais c'est
très important aussi pour l'immigration
pour résoudre pas le problème de
l'immigration si nous ne reprenons pas
la maîtrise de nos frontières par
exemple donc là il doit y avoir des
possibilités de transgresser la libre
circulation à l'intérieur de l'Europe
comment croyez-vous que les gens
arrivent à caler
ils arrivent pas à caler
ils viennent d'ailleurs souvent
d'Allemagne d'ailleurs ils traversent
ils vont à Calais pour aller en
Angleterre
si vous les empêchez pas de rentrer et
vous les aurez toujours à Calais et puis
à Calais pour les pour les
pour les évacuer de la c'est très
compliqué aussi c'est le résultat d'un
accord entre Nicolas Sarkozy qui était
ministre de l'Intérieur
et la Grande-Bretagne il faudrait
remettre en cause il faut remettre en
cause cet accord mais il faut se donner
aussi les moyens que les flux ne
continuent pas enfin que les réfugiés ne
contiennent pas à affluer à caler sinon
sinon le problème n'est pas résolu voilà
le nous n'avons pas de dire au
Britannique c'est à vous de gérer ça on
n'est pas là
je me souviens de cette façon les
Britanniques avec nous certains
candidats dis bon on a qu'à les mettre
sur des séries et puis ils ont envoyé un
Angleterre ils ne seront pas débarquer
puis voilà ou alors vous les laissez se
noyer mais enfin
vous pouvez les jeter à la mer sur des
sur des sur des radeaux mais
ça va pas durer longtemps ça je voyais
bien il y a des gens qui se noient et
qui meurent en métal donc le problème
c'est c'est de savoir comment on fait
pour qu'il n'arrive pas à caler de toute
façon ils ne veulent pas rester bon donc
si vous continuez avec le principe de
libre circulation
intangible absolue mettre des frontières
à l'intérieur de l'espace il faut de
toute façon nous avons un problème
général qui avec la frontière nous
devons toute façon pouvoir maîtriser nos
frontières ce qui veut pas dire
s'enfermer avec des derrière des
barbelés des murs infranchissables mais
que ce soit pour le pour l'immigration
que ce soit pour l'économie
nous avons besoin de frontières voilà
sinon il peut plus avoir il peut y avoir
démocratie un peu plus y avoir de il
peut plus y avoir de souveraineté parce
que le peuple qui ne maîtrise pas cet
espace dans lequel il vit
n'a plus aucun pouvoir sur son destin
bon donc là la question de savoir
comment on fait elle est simple il
faudra il faudra de toute façon à un
moment ou un autre arrivé modifier
l'article 55 de la Constitution vous ne
pourrez le faire à mon sens que par un
référendum alors il y a un débat
terrible peut-être l'article 55 c'est
celui qui dit que les traités sont
supérieurs à la loi nationale donc
comme le traité de
maastrichtensternuts européens mais
aussi des traités de libre-échange les
conventions internationales etc donc
quand la loi est contraire le juge dit
ah ben non c'est la loi c'est la loi
c'est la loi supérieure qui s'applique
donc ça sert à rien donc ça sert à rien
de voter ça sert à rien d'avoir un
parlement si au fur et à mesure que le
temps passe son son pouvoir se réduit à
voter des lois qui ne sont plus
appliquées
ça sert à rien ça les signer les traités
mais non parce qu'il s'agit pas il
s'agit pas de dire que tous les traités
sont à sont ajoutés sont achetés à la
poubelle il s'agit d'agir avec
discernement c'est on peut demander ça
si si vous vous mettez au pouvoir des
gens qui n'ont aucun discernement de
toute façon il y a pas de solution mais
on peut attendre du discernement et sur
certains points se dire à certains
moments que
s'il y a des choses qui ne sont pas
acceptables que nous que nos partenaires
ne veulent pas renégocier bien vous
dites voilà c'est la loi qui envoie
après tout nous avons vécu jusqu'en 1989
pour le droit public et 75 pour le
institutions judiciaires sous l'Empire
d'une interprétation de ce de ce
d'article 55 de la Constitution
qui voulait que ce soit la dernière
expression de la volonté du législateur
qui l'emporte alors législateur il
expriment ça sa volonté en ratifiant les
traités et en votant les lois si la loi
était donc postérieure au traité c'est
la loi qui s'appliquait ça n'a pas
empêché l'Europe d'avancer ça n'a pas
créé un véritable chaos c'est l'article
55 il était il était fait il a été fait
dans une époque il a été écrit comme ça
dans une époque où
les engagements internationaux n'avaient
pas le même sens qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui se sont étendu à
beaucoup de choses que vous que vous
disiez que le droit maritime ou le droit
aérien ou le droit qui régit les Détroit
la libre circulation dans les détroits
ne peut pas être mis en cause par une
simple loi ordinaire sans discuter avec
les autres sinon c'est la guerre en fait
c'est la guerre on résout tous les
conflits avec la guerre je le comprends
mais c'était ça la logique de ces de
cette hiérarchie des normes entre les
traités et la loi nationale mais quand
vous signez un traité de libre-échange
qui rentre dans le pacte social dans le
pacte national dans toutes les normes
d'hygiène sécurité de la société on est
plus du tout dans la même dans le même
ordre des choses c'est pareil pour
l'Europe personne à l'époque n'imaginait
à quel point le droit dérivé des traités
en Europe a laissé tendre à quel point
le pouvoir des juridictions allait
s'étendre mais savez-vous que nous
n'avons jamais signé un traité en Europe
où il est écrit que le droit européen
est supérieur au droit national jamais
c'est une décision jurisprudentielle de
la Cour de
justice de européenne qu'il a décrété en
64 et ça ne nous a pas empêché encore
une fois jusqu'en 75 pour le
institutions judiciaires et jusqu'en
1989 pour le droit public français pour
le pour le pour le conseiller d'État de
ne pas respecter cette décision et donc
il est urgent c'est la clé c'est la
reprendre l'article 55
et effectivement c'est intéressant parce
que c'est effectivement c'est un point
qu'on soulève finalement assez peu dans
les dans les discussions on est plus
plus
les républicains un peu soulevé mais à
mon sens qui est insuffisamment disons
travailler penser voilà dans tous les
cas on sent que vous l'avez travaillé et
vous l'avez explosé avec avec talent et
pédagogie leur exposé dans le Figaro
dans une page au moins il y a deux ans
justement on va y revenir également il y
a d'autres pages sur lesquelles vous
êtes revenus une tribune on va y venir
notamment sur l'inflation pas de
question quand même avant le
gouvernement et la majorité tentent par
tous les moyens de à la proposition de
la loi liotte de loi liotte contre la
réforme des retraites est-ce que cette
bonne guerre ou ça va trop loin selon
vous mais ça va trop loin depuis le
début depuis le début on utilise la
Constitution comme il ne faut pas
l'utiliser ça c'est pas parce que c'est
écrit c'est devenu une tendance
d'ailleurs générale tout le monde dit
j'ai bien le droit d'eux et va au bout
de sa propre logique
c'est pas parce qu'il y a un article en
9 3 qui est utile dans la constitution
ou un article 47 1 qui permet de
raccourcir terriblement les délais de de
discussion de la loi parce qu'il s'agit
de textes de financement ou un article
du règlement ou un article qui permet
parlons de faire un vote bloqué ou un
article comme l'article 40 qu'on invoque
maintenant pour la pour le projet de loi
enfin la proposition de loi sur l'iode
sur les sur les retraites que qu'il faut
l'utiliser n'importe comment personne
n'avait utilisé de 47 ans depuis le
début de la cinquième vue de cette façon
personne n'avait utilisé non plus de
cette façon le 49
on ne respecte pas la nécessité de se
donner des limites dans l'exercice de
son pouvoir voilà et donc si on utilise
le type de gouvernement utilise
l'article 40 il va finir par détruire la
Constitution parce que tout le monde va
imputer le le l'exercice actuel du
pouvoir à la constitution est-ce que la
question néanmoins la réforme des
retraites mérite selon vous d'être
reposé ou bien est-ce que maintenant ça
a été voté et il faut passer à autre
chose non la démocratie c'est que quand
vous n'êtes pas d'accord vous pouvez
toujours contester jusqu'au bout pendant
que la loi il faut faire un référendum
selon vous ah je pense qu'il fallait
faire un référendum et qu'il faut le
faire je pense que le Président de la
République ne le fera peut-être pas mais
il se grandirait en le faisant il
grandirait et l'institution et lui-même
et si c'est perdu et alors c'est le
peuple qui tranche il y a pas il n'y a
pas de honte à perdre contre le peuple
si on trouve que c'est que le peuple a
vraiment tort par rapport à propre point
de vue alors on fait comme le général on
s'en va ou bien on dit simplement que à
la dernière fois Jacques Chirac on perd
le référendum et on reste ça peut
arriver il y a pas de raison que
n'importe quel référendum perdu entraîne
au départ du président ça c'est ça ça
dépend du président soit il pose la
question de confiance il dit si vous
votez non je peux pas gouverner sans ça
par exemple quelqu'un mettrait l'article
55 de la Constitution au référendum je
pense qu'il serait logique d'engager la
question de confiance vis-à-vis du
peuple là cela réforme des retraites à
mon sens il n'est pas nécessaire
d'engager là mais il est nécessaire
imaginé président de la République
venant à la télévision et disons je
voilà je pense que cette réforme est la
bonne qu'elle est nécessaire très bien
mais je vois bien qu'elle divise les
Français par conséquent c'est à vous
c'est à vous de trancher
je la mets au référendum par l'article
11 de la Constitution de la sommaire
référendum et bien si si les Français
disent non présenterables peut-être le
peuple la tranché point et et en fait on
améliore on renforcera l'autorité de la
fonction et
institution
jamais on gagne jamais en opposant un
gouvernant avec son orgueil contre le
peuple je pense que c'est question
encore une question poétique intérieure
avant de passer à l'Ukraine pourquoi
vous voulez vous indexer des salaires
sur l'inflation c'est la seule c'est une
solution absolue selon vous pour lutter
une nécessité oui c'est une nécessité
parce que les salaires étaient déjà trop
bas et contrairement à ce qu'on a
beaucoup raconté en faisant dire
statistiques ce qu'elle ne disent pas
parce que ce sont des moyennes c'est
vrai là le pouvoir d'achat du travail a
baissé continuellement depuis plusieurs
décennies bon et donc après on peut pas
dire que il faut valoriser le travail
qu'il faut que le travail paye et puis
continuer à laisser des salaires réels
c'est-à-dire ce qui est vraiment salaire
avec quoi ce pouvoir d'achat du salaire
baissé continuellement avec avec une
inflation qui est de 5 à 6% par an ça
veut dire c'est on va on va on va à
l'explosion sociale et on peut pas et à
la dévalorisation totale du travail donc
il faut arrêter ça est-ce qu'il faut
pour autant maintenir alors discussion
qu'on avait auparavant à Guillaume
Rocket le niveau des prestations
sociales et à particulier des
allocations chômage dans le au niveau où
elles sont aujourd'hui
elles ont été beaucoup baissé le
problème c'est de réduire le chômage
pourquoi on en est là on en est là parce
que pendant des décennies on a pris des
décisions de politique économiques qui
ont détruit l'économie et la société
voilà en particulier on a fait
n'importe quoi avec les frontières on a
fait n'importe quoi avec la
mondialisation sans sans précaution et
c'est ça
pulvérisé les sociétés occidentales
quand une fois les États-Unis c'est pas
simplement un problème de valeur c'est
aussi que ce qu'on appelle les la classe
moyenne blanche aux États-Unis des
ouvriers a été
toute la variété percutée
pari donc d'ailleurs on voit bien que
les Américains essaient maintenant que
droite et gauche confondues de faire
revenir leurs activités pour des raisons
à la fois de société et pour des raisons
de sécurité ou d'indépendance donc nous
sommes tous confrontés à ça
[Musique]